my dream threesome would be dr. Phil and
Judge Judy
you need help you need serious help
serious serious help hey I'm dr. Phil
I'm hanging out at BuzzFeed today and
I'm gonna be reading your thirsty tweets
so we'll see what you've got to say I
think dr. Phil kind of sexy so I think
my type is older men ouch
that can handle my emotional issues well
I was doing okay till you said older I
mean come on I have to rock being bald
every day and then you got to call me
older handle my emotional issues I'm
only dr. Phil on the show when I get
home I'm worthless I'm like a lizard on
a rock so I don't want to handle your
emotional issues at home thanks for
calling me kinda sexy and kind of sexy
you see me with my shirt off I wouldn't
let dr. Phil top me I would let dr. Phil
top me okay you still need to know what
taught me means it's a little sexual oh
well thank you dr. Phil is so sexy
notice not kind of dr. Phil is so sexy
to me just because he is intelligent
rational and communicates beautifully
just so you know I'm not making these up
of course you may think I type this up
before I got here but I didn't you know
intelligence is sexy
communication is sexy which is a good
thing because when you're old involved
you kind of have something you rock it
better be your brains this peoplein
spell tune in to look at me that's for
sure it looks like an old catcher's mitt
sometimes I want to kiss dr. Phil on the
lips thanks Robin I appreciate you
tweeting you guys are trying to
embarrass me here until I'm very much
attracted to dr. Phil his shiny bald
head is such a turn-on had to go there
didn't you
you know I rarely study the other day
that said 78% of men would rather
amputate a body part than be bald can
you believe that
you're not cutting it off of me oh my
god dr. Phil has the biggest smile
really I do smile a lot and we actually
laugh a lot on the dr. Phil show
it's just that doesn't go viral people
don't pick that up they
get up when I throw somebody off page or
something it's a long win oh my god dr.
Phil is the wallpaper on my phone now
and I couldn't be happier just looking
at this man's beautiful face makes my
whole day better oh you must have a
really [ __ ] day no I'm glad maybe it
calms you down or maybe it makes you
less rescue today look better put me on
your ringtone maybe asking you how's
that working for you dr. Phil is so
conceptually who his face a seat you're
saying as long as I got a face you got a
place to sit all right I get it
see I'm not that old all right look this
has been a lot of fun I don't know who
put this bucket together but it has been
fun I'll see you on the show so long
adios see you guys
[Music]